菲姐姐为啥每天这么幸福？
哎呦，
这事儿说起来她是一个可以写论文的话题，
你要问我每为啥每天这么幸福，
因为我确实我觉得我干这个工作挺有意思呀，
干这个工作挺有用啊，
对大家来说的话，
它确实挺有价值啊，
这真的是衬托了我的很多的那种幸福感，
再加上因为我从小就是苦日子，
从小那么穷，
一路走过来也是一种对比。
还有就是我老看历史，
姐妹们就老看历史了之后你发现我们中国人在这块土地上能吃饱饭也就这几十年的时间，
能吃饱饭以前就算你在大唐盛世，
就算你在康乾盛世，
我们作为老百姓能吃饱饭都不容易，
我不知道有多少人能够跟龙飞有这个共鸣，
所以我就想把她运气怎么那么好啊，
怎么出生在这么好的年代，
尤其是作为女人，
我出生在80后，
我可赶上历史上最好的时候了，
我得好好过我这一生。
现在我看到很多兄弟姐妹的抑郁吗？
其实我心里老想，
如果你们的思维方式，
或者说让龙飞的灵魂钻进你们的脑子里的话，
真的能解决很多的问题方面就是因为从历史上来看，
这块土地上生存的老百姓能吃饱饭就这么几十年，
再有就是女性能自己工作，
能读大学，
能求学，
能有自己的。
继承权，
能有财产权，
能有投票权，
也就这些年，
再加上我，
真的是我不图像人家似的说成名成家，
不图说挣好多老多钱哦，
然后那个给乡亲们捐路修房子啊，
或者是那个盖学校什么的，
我我们对自己没有这么高的期待，
对自己的期待就是平平安安做个普通人，
平平安安活到老，
体验一下这世间的繁华。
所以我感觉我们女性啊，
尤其是像我们出生于70后80后这些女性啊，
真是赶上好时候啊，
我感觉50后60后都可苦了，
她们都不一定能吃饱，
尤其是改革开放出身的这些女性，
包括男同学，
我们最起码是很少有饿肚子的人生体验啊。
刚刚有朋友菲菲说的真好，
真的很庆幸跟在红旗下，
长在春风里，
接受了良好的教育，
有一份不错的工作和收入，
我有的时候就是暗自窃喜，
因为我这个人吧，
我不太适合过那种宿舍生活，
集体生活，
说一个单位啊，
都住一个楼，
我就感觉我过那样的生活都还挺拘束，
像我自己就赶上了好时候，
我不用说一个单位住一栋楼屋啊，
全是认识的人，
因为我这人可能道德品质也没有那么好，
就是全都认识的人在那儿的话，
那不得凑合，
心思淹死，
我就没感觉。
不用非得在一个集体里也能生存下来，
我感觉挺好，
非常好，
特别适合我。
刚刚有人说妹妹认知很高，
我感觉这都不叫认知高，
这叫我们普通人过日子能观察的自己的这个生存现状哦，
姐姐，
像你们年纪比我们大一点的，
你们可能比我们吃的苦更多一点啊，
记得点赞关注哦。